absolutely i believe in the power of
storytelling or
art to change the world absolutely
let us start at the beginning you wanted
honolulu but you were brought up in in
sydney
and i imagine this was a house where
there were
books and cinema and theater and all
those things
were a regular part of growing up is
that right not so much cinema
i mean books science
politics um emotions
and um a very tight close-knit family
were you absolutely set
on performing there was nothing in my
family that suggested to be
an actress which is why i've always said
it's in my blood i don't know where it
came from
but it's like a pull and a calling
and as much as i try to move away from
it and there's been times when i have
it's like this slow thing that pulls me
back
and it gives me enormous um
joy but it also puts me in a place of
being able to
communicate was there a sort of plan or
then were you thinking
you know this is this is a plan there's
still no plan
i mean i follow um my heart and i follow
sometimes i'll i'm
very whimsical i'll choose to do things
on a whim
i like not feeling trapped it must get
more difficult
when you win baftas and oscars and
things like that
isn't there a sense that you've got more
to lose
you know there's a expectation but
so then you don't live up to that
expectation for a year or two and then
you
um rise up again or you discover
something else
in my case i went and met somebody and i
fell in love and i actually
had a whole different path in terms of
what i wanted to do i
i was very lonely so i went okay i'm now
going to
try and meet my partner and and put
and that takes time you know and it
can't be working all the time and
flitting off around the world so i
actually sort of
went far more inward than the thing it
did was it highlighted to me
the idea that i was um quite you know
that i needed to go and have
more of a real life because i had an
incredible
artistic life i just didn't have the
balance there there's films that you do
because
those stories need to be put in the
world there um
they're sort of there's a reason for
them
politically or um emotionally to be out
there and then there's other films that
are entertainment there's other films
that are just
i have to this story i connect to
do you think films can change things
shining light onto things or even
putting it out into the conversation
raising people's awareness um
yeah all of those things go into whether
they
immediately change things or whether
they slowly drip drip
change things i absolutely i believe in
the power of storytelling or
art to change the world absolutely
[Music]
you